we are hoping to get a new Stargate
franchise really soon we're getting very
excited about it on this channel and
asking lots of really big questions
about what that new show should look
like
but there's one question I'm really
interested by
would the SGC even still be active
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
move the channel
so I put a comment on Twitter and it
basically said look when Stargate
command comes back should the Stargate
program be revealed to the public or
should it still be a secret we know that
Brad Wright when he was looking at his
new script for the Stargate show that he
was playing with MGM just before covid
that the Stargate program was going to
be revealed to the public we also know
that the third straighter DVD movie back
in the day was going to center around
Richard Dean Anderson and revealing the
Stargate project to the public so we
know this is something that Brad Wright
hoped to do
but then somebody commented on that and
they sort of said well how do we even
know the SGC is still operational maybe
after the disaster of Stargate Universe
the loss of an entire planet the loss of
resources to the Lucian Alliance attack
Etc that maybe the SGC will have been
shut down maybe we will have become a
internal centralized Nation just
protecting ourselves and maybe the
politicians of the day would have
decided actually to close the Stargate
program
now this got me thinking because we all
know that politicians have short-sighted
we also know that from many episodes of
Stargate that actually they did try to
close the Stargate program down more
than once Commander Thor
my name is Senator Kinsey
O'Neill suggested I send you to a
distant planet for your actions here but
I am reasonably certain his statement
was ingest I'm sure it was commander
Supreme Commander
we also know that having the Stargate
program had put Earth in the fiery line
of every big bad in the galaxy and that
we actually only survived as a species
through the skill of sg1 and let's be
honest look
so an argument within the senate or the
UN to actually say now they've got a
world are gone the replicators are gone
the Asgard are gone the aura are gone
and so on and so on maybe we should stop
sending teams through the Stargate now
there were advantages obviously
technological advantages being the main
one for going through the game but while
the gate is secret very little of that
technology was actually filtering down
to Real World stuff we never saw in the
show say new power course being used we
gave them to other people we got the
natural reactors and we gave them to
little villages on far off worlds
but not once did we ever see in the real
show that technology being used on Earth
now
we know we were building a pretty
Advanced Fleet of Starships the BC 304s
by now we can imagine that there'd be BC
305s b3306s and that these vessels would
be pretty much the baddest vessels in
the Galaxy that we know about the Lucian
Alliance we're using gold wool
technology and our Asgard Shields Asgard
weapons Etc could cut through them like
a hot knife through butter
so we could maybe assume that even if we
had lesser numbers in the Lucian
Alliance that actually we were way more
effective and that we could easily
defend ourselves with a small number of
vessels in orbit we wouldn't necessarily
need to be going in and out through the
Stargate
there's also another big problem with
going in there through the Stargate we
kept finding people that really needed
our help I mean not just like fighting
the gold world but how many billions of
people were out in the Galaxy living in
abject poverty that would maybe need
that support need our guidance need our
resources now I don't know about you but
a lot of politics in America and in the
west already is very inward looking I'm
not sure that a humanitarian effort of
that Grandeur would even be considered
and whether it even be possible
so even though us going out into the
stars and setting up an Empire perhaps
within the Galaxy would be a very
interesting Prospect for many I could
also see that many politicians would be
terrified by the idea
and actually I do think the Stargate
program being closed by those
narrow-minded short-sighted politicians
particularly after what happened with
Stargate Universe
would be a very real possibility
that loss of life that loss of resources
and that attack on that planet again by
the Lucian Alliance and the problems
being caused by the Lucian Alliance
might have just been enough to give the
doubters the reason to kick the SGC to
the curb
but if that did happen would that make
for a more interesting new show well
this guy on this comment argued that
yeah okay it might not be a very popular
way of starting it but from a writing
point of view he could see how it would
work and so could I they could mirror
really the very opening episodes of
Stargate sg1 in lots of ways
a new enemy coming through the closed
gate a new threat that forces us to once
again return to the stars and start
using the Stargates I actually do wonder
if this is actually a quite a logical
way to start the new series but actually
also quite an easy way for writers to do
it and I've always argued that we want
Stargate and not Star Trek and the way
we were going with technology moving
forwards at the moment at the end of sg1
SG Atlantis it was becoming Star Trek we
were too advanced
perhaps while we were off air that a big
backward step into ourselves is a
perfect way to create a foundation for a
new franchise
a little bit of a backward step to allow
us to take a big step forwards with the
new show hey this is just an idea but
actually is it a logical one I'd love
you guys to get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think even if
you don't necessarily like it knowing
what you know about politicians
does it make it possible one I think so
I'd love to know guys though exactly
what you think and if you think there
are any better ideas out there for a way
to re-kick start this franchise in a way
that is realistic exciting and still
Stargate I'd love to know exactly what
you think get in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack or a small contribution
each month and you get most of our
videos first and you don't have to watch
the adverts there's even an option for a
seven day free trial to see how it works
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]